Hello, I have Hashimoto's and
Eardable bowel syndrome invited it hard to find healthy proteins to eat
with every meal
That are so a free gluten-free dairy free
No peanuts as I have noticed they make me swell up. Thank you so much. So
Eardable bowel syndrome
is
basically a collection of
Symptoms that people get a diagnosis of that isn't specific so
You can can can a celiac cause irritable bowel syndrome. Yeah, well, can food in
Food antibodies cause irritable bowel syndrome. Yeah, so you have this collection of symptoms that were to call irritable bowel syndrome
Could it be Crohn's disease which is an autoimmune?
Disorder, but if you haven't been tested the answers. Yes, it could be so you want to do some more testing
If you have
gluten sensitivity, dairy sensitivity, you notice that peanuts bother you, you notice that soy bothers you
It might be good to do a
Cyrex array
10 lab test if you haven't done that already
And that's going to test for other foods that you may be sensitive to
Because you could be sensitive to different proteins different meat products
You could be sensitive to you know other nuts have protein in it other things that you're trying to eat that maybe don't bother
You right at the time that you eat, but then you have it and it exacerbates your other symptoms
So it's hard to find if you have multiple food antibodies
It's hard to pinpoint
What they are sometimes because you're not necessarily eating
Any of these foods
You know uniquely at one given time to tell you if I know it was that as much as it would
But as much as it might be easy if you ate gluten or dairy or peanuts
so running a
Cyrex array 10 lab to
To really investigate deeper what foods that you need to calm down how you need to eliminate those foods for a period of time to calm down
The inflammation your gut might be a good thing to do
Otherwise, we're just shooting in the dark. You could Google a list of proteins and start eating them
And there's another row of that. Let's say
I don't know who you are, but you might say I don't have money to run a lab like that. That's a lot of money
Can I just try this in my own? Well, certainly you could Google a list of
Proteins and try them one by one and boy I can eat lamb that doesn't bother me
But if I chicken that bothers me. Okay, then you might have antibodies to chicken and you might not with lamb or fish or whatever it is and you could go one by one to
You know basically test yourself with the food elimination type diet
So that that's safe to do that too
But running a Cyrex 10 might be a wise thing to do if you couldn't afford to do